fred when when people ask me about you
no matter what it has to do with the
show one of the main things is everybody
asks
why is he there
no spread is so fast on the sound
effects fred is so smart with the sound
effects so tell us how do you do it well
i'm sitting here and i'm talking to you
for example and i go okay here's a piece
of music i want to play
chuck mangione feels so good and uh
whatever goes through my mind which is a
terrible thing
[Music]
that's the infamous gary
gary playing his trumpet with james
brown
[Music]
anything that you can throw in there to
kind of make things a little different
that's really what it is it's like
whatever floats through my mind in that
moment so now we got a little look into
your mind and how you do it and
everything but let's go so now
you went from this file cabinet of
course to this wall like walls and walls
of carts so the question becomes
how did you know where everything is and
how were you able to get it so quickly
it was chaos it was total chaos and uh
i've read many things about that where
they say people who are just sloppy in
slobs or whatever it's like uh
they're creative i don't know if i'm
creative but
it seems to be the case for me
i just remembered where all the
important [ __ ] was
and uh sometimes i had to plan it out a
little bit more i would have like
certain stacks in certain places like
okay that i know i'm going to use a lot
that one's my secondary stack that's my
tertiary stack once or twice a year
you would hear the stacks fall over and
i always go fred was like the original
it was like chengdu right because you
would try to pull a card out from the
bottom of the stack and it would make
all the poison it was it would be like
the creaking of a ship then all sudden
everything would just break loose it's
like
well not quite like that but i mean
no but it would be that it would be that
startling robin and howard would be
talking then all of a sudden i'd be
trying to go for a sound effect to make
things a little funnier than the
unexpected crash would happen so now we
we move into like modern technology we
get this machine it's called an instant
replay it's digital it's much quicker to
get to things so the question becomes
now that you're using that how do you
know where everything is so quickly
again you know they all went in at a
certain time
and somehow it got planted into my brain
like for example if i go to number 14 i
know that's an important number
yeah number 14 is hey now there you go
so that's hay now and then you've got
this guy yeah
you know gold dust it's like it's just
so weird it's like they're just certain
things that you remember
and over the course of time i just kind
of memorized them it's crazy nuts
there's easier ways to do it there's
better ways to do it there's more
organized ways to do it i just never did
that